Not too far from Earth.
It's a giant space rock that is silently played host to just 12 people in its
entire history.
What would happen if we put our cosmic satellite to work by covering it with
solar panels?
What would it take to build an enormous power plant on the moon?
How big would this facility be and how much time would it take to finish this
mega construction?
This is what if,
and here's what would happen if we covered the moon with solar panels
because the moon has little to no atmosphere.
There's no wind,
no rain,
and no clouds on that space rock.
If a lunar weatherman were to tell you the forecast,
it would always be the same.
One more
time.
Tell me,
mommy,
imagine how much energy we'd collect from a place where the sun never stopped
shining,
but how would we even build a solar plant on the mood?
One Japanese company Shimizu already has that covered.
They want to build a so called Luna ring and yes,
it would look just the way it sounds.
A ring of solar panels spinning around the moon.
The construction would stretch for 11,000 kilometers along the moon's equator
and would reach 400 kilometers in width.
That's enough to cover half of the United States.
Where on earth would we even find enough materials for assembling this enormous
solar plant?
Well,
the answer lies outside of our planet's natural budget.
Most of the building materials would come from the moon itself.
We'd only have to launch the initial equipment over there,
just enough to start building more equipment and manufacturing lunar robots.
Then a team of robots together with a group of astronauts would handle the rest.
For starters,
they'd construct huge excavator and or processing machines to mine the moon.
Then they begin assembling solar panels from the lunar materials with nothing
but lunar,
soil and gravel.
They'd make concrete ceramics and solar cells.
Meanwhile,
astronauts on earth would be working on building spaceports in low earth orbit
to ship the remaining suppliers like hydrogen to the moon.
Even with the most advanced technology we can think of.
The construction would take at least two generations of humans to complete,
but once it's done,
we'd have a super efficient lunar power plant churning out power 24 seven
because there are no bad weather days on the moon ever.
But what about getting that power back to earth?
Well,
that's the fun part on the moon.
The lunar power plant would transmit solar power to the energy converting
facilities.
From there,
the converted power would be being to power collecting stations on earth with
lasers,
microwaves.
How cool is that?
Potentially it could deliver so much energy that we wouldn't need any other
power sources at all.
Maybe building the lunar power plant would happen.
At the same time,
we constructed a human occupied moon base that would one day grow into a fully
operational human colony.
But that's a story for another.
What if.